armadillos are one of the most
delightful animals out there they're
Strang looking silly and surprisingly
fearless and though tempting you should
never ever touch one because despite how
cute they are they are riddled with one
of the most ancient diseases in recorded
human history one that causes skin
lesions disfigurement and death leprosy
leprosy is caused by the bacterium
microbacterium lepre and it's only ever
been found to infect humans and oddly
armadillos but why do armadillos get
this very specific human disease new
research shows that armadillos and
humans keep passing the disease back and
forth they get it from digging in
infected soil and we get it from
touching eating or otherwise interacting
with armadillos it's a disease that
likely started in Armadillos and then
mutated to spread to humans in the
southern us more than 20% of armadillos
are infected with leprosy in Brazil it
could be as high as 60%